let's go to our next caller from the 208
area code call her from 208 who's this
hello this is mica from Idaho
go ahead mica um I was I was just
wondering because you had I was watching
an interview you did a while back with
someone of the atheist community and I
forgot his name but he was calling you
an atheist and I was wondering because
you seemed to kind of distance yourself
from that title and I was wondering if
that was due to sort of an ideological
disagreement you have with it or if it's
more due to distancing yourself from the
guy whoever no listen I don't have any
particular problem I mean here's the
thing I don't know the interview you're
talking about and there may have been
some like very specific definitions that
were being used it might have been like
a semantic disagreement I don't really
know I mean I don't I can't think of any
so-called religious belief that I hold
and I'm open to having my mind change
and I believe that it's possible that
there is a God or some higher power or a
creator I've just not yet been presented
with anything that I would consider
worthy of making me believe that and
whether whether that makes me agnostic
or atheist I don't know and I don't know
that it's that important you know but
like I'm a secular person I'm a
non-religious person I think the
phenomena of our world that we haven't
yet found explanations for have an
explanation that we might someday find
but I don't find the absence of that
explanation indicative of proof of God
you know that that's my bully I don't
know what label you want to put on that
for sure um I think if I'm allowed to go
on just for a few more second please
please um yes but I think far by the
same token that we call the theist
atheist because they believe in the God
based on the evidence that's been
presented to them yep I think that by
that same token you can say that you're
an atheist because you haven't been
presented with that evidence oh yeah
what I would mean I think here's the
thing there's basically there's two ways
that people sometimes define atheist
sometimes atheist
and I'm talking colloquially right I
think you're completely right about the
actual definition but in popular culture
atheist is sometimes seen as the person
who positively believes there is no God
and agnostic is the person who just
believes none none has been demonstrated
yet now I know that you're sort of
giving a different definition so maybe
it was like under that understanding of
what it means to be a theist that I said
I'm agnostic not atheist I just don't
remember the interview in question
though you know okay yeah yeah all right
Micah
thank you very much glad I was able to
answer your question let's take a quick
break if you're on hold don't hang up
because we are going to take more phone
calls in mere moments